más de dos meses después de llegar al
poder en afganistán los talibanes están
en una ofensiva diplomática con la
intención de ser reconocidos
internacionalmente se sentaron con
funcionarios de eeuu y de la unión
europea en doha el grupo está
desesperado por la ayuda extranjera para
detener la caída del país en el colapso
económico
afganistán es una parte importante del
mundo islámico también queremos tener
lazos únicos con el mundo occidental y
los países del golfo y el mundo árabe
afganistán no quiere verse envuelto en
disputas extranjeras sino que quiere
tener relaciones positivas con todos
y la comunidad internacional ha
descartado por ahora el reconocimiento
del gobierno de kabul algo que según los
fundamentalistas podría empeorar la
situación del pueblo afgano que de por
sí es el tema central de una cumbre
especial del g20 en roma' antes de la
reunión la unión europea acordó
desbloquear mil millones de euros en
ayuda humanitaria el bloque e insistió
en que el dinero iría directamente a las
agencias de ayuda que trabajan sobre el
terreno y no a los funcionarios
talibanes en kabul
quiero saludar especialmente el hecho de
que la unión europea a través de la voz
de la presidenta de la comisión europea
haya puesto hoy a disposición mil
millones de euros adicionales para
tareas relacionadas con afganistán
quedarse de brazos cruzados y ver como
40 millones de personas según dan en el
caos porque no se puede suministrar
electricidad y no existe un sistema
financiero ese no puede ser el objetivo
de la comunidad internacional
manchester pero los líderes occidentales
se enfrentan a un delicado acto de
equilibrio como hacer llegar la ayuda al
pueblo afgano sin refrendar al régimen
talibán